one of the things we've been talking
about in a sort of hypothetical sense
since the riots
in washington dc on january 6th is
if instead of being a mostly white male
conservative crowd there
storming the capital fighting with
police pushing police with barriers
hitting police with fire extinguishers
and on and on and on
if it had been a black lives matter
protest if the political orientation had
been different or the racial makeup of
the people there had been different
would it have been allowed to go on for
as long as it did would it have been
handled in the same way and i think
intuitively most of us who understand
the way things have gone down in the
united states for the last many years
can only come to the conclusion that no
it would not have been the same
if the protests last week had been
different groups of people in terms of
their makeup
or politically oriented in a different
way
we don't just have to intuit
our sense of that because we actually
have a study about this and barack obama
shared this on his twitter account
recently
and the study was led was done by ack
led acled
it's a data reporting project and it
looked
initially they used to look at armed
conflicts in african
countries and then they started looking
at the united states and in the united
states we've had so many
protests slash riots of different kinds
that there's plenty of fodder and
and data to look at and what
ak-led found is that law enforcement
is much more likely to try to shut down
left-wing protests than they are
right-wing protests when law enforcement
uses force to shut them down
they are much more likely to use force
in the left-wing protests than in the
right-wing protests by a
51 percent to 34 margin
more than half the time when they decide
to shut down a left-wing protest they
use force
only about a third of the time when they
decide to shut down a right-wing protest
they use force and um there are
a number of different things to consider
here you might say well
maybe the left-wing protests are more
violent
and thus it makes sense that police
are more likely to try to shut them down
or to use force that is not what the
data
actually shows the data does not show
that left-wing protests
are more violent than right-wing
protests
another consideration would be where
are the left-wing versus the right-wing
protest taking place in other words
political orientation of the protest
aside
are the left-wing protests happening in
places
whose police departments for other
reasons are more likely
to prevent them from going on too long
whereas the right-wing protests are
happening in places whose police
department
departments are more lacks in allowing
them to go on that also
does not appear to be the case and so
this is a really um a this is not a
trivial
thing uh and and where i believe
much of the investigation needs to be
is in the political orientation
not just of the police officers but
of the police departments and this also
includes
mayors we know that law enforcement is a
relatively conservative group
law enforcement in total supported trump
in 2020 at a much greater level than the
average population
so of course there are liberal police
departments and police departments with
liberal police chiefs or that work under
liberal mayors there's no doubt about
that
but overall the makeup of the officers
tends to be far more right-wing
than the average population this also
applies to the military although we did
see in 2020
that the military was more supportive of
joe biden
than they've been of most past
democratic candidates at least going
back
a number of elections so certainly we
have to consider
whether the political orientation of the
officers
plays a role and also if you have
right-wing officers but a more centrist
or center-left
police chief and mayor how does that
affect the handling of protesters
what we know is that when we talk about
the right to protest if the left-wing
protests
aren't more violent and we know that
they are not
but yet police are more likely oh and
the left-wing protesters are not more
likely to be armed
and they are not then we have to say
well why is it
that the left-wing protests are more
likely to be shut down and is that
is that a restriction of speech and
we've seen
right-wingers either misunderstand or
pretend not to understand
when the first amendment is a factor you
know twitter suspending trump is not a
first amendment issue it has nothing to
do with the first amendment
we hear all the time my first amendment
rights my first amendment rights trump's
first amendment rights when it has
nothing to do with the first amendment
but when you see a political discrepancy
in which protests are shut down along
the lines of the political orientation
or motivations of the protest by police
under the guidance of police chiefs city
councils mayors etc
you really actually have to start asking
questions about whether the government
is suppressing speech
and suppressing it along political lines
so
none of this is is a catch-all that
explains every circumstance but it's a
very good data analysis
538 has a write-up about it again the
the organization that did the analysis
is acled a-c-l-e-d
and we'll link to the article about it
in the description
on the youtube clip for this story take
a look at it let me know what you think
you can find me
on twitter at dpakman